ils viennent de faire plus de 270 km à
bord de leur voiture et s'est soulagé et
à fab et que ces ukrainiens arrive sur
ce parquet certains ont des enfants en
bas âge en témoignent ses pancartes ils
font partie des vingt mille personnes à
avoir quitté marioupol depuis un couloir
humanitaire mais tous ne sont pas encore
arrivés au bout des milliers d'autres
sont encore coincés sur la route
un convoi d'aidé humanitaire pour
marioupol restent encore bloqués mais
depuis quelques jours les gens
parviennent peu à peu à quitter la ville
assiégée grâce à des transports privés
marioupol c'est la grande ville
portuaire située à une cinquantaine de
km de la frontière russe et surtout à 85
km du fief séparatistes de donetsk c'est
aussi la plus grande ville encore aux
mains de kiev dans le donbass les russes
veulent à tout prix sont emparés
car c'est la pièce manquante pour
contrôler la mer d'azov et pour faire la
jonction avec la crim est annexée et les
troupes séparatistes dans le nom passe à
6 g donc par les forces depuis plusieurs
jours marioupol est devenue une ville
fantôme qui vit au rythme des
bombardements et contraint sa population
à rester terré dans des caches
eux aussi fui l'horreur de la guerre par
un autre couloir humanitaire depuis la
ville de soumis dans le nord-est de
l'ukraine tout près de la russie dans
ces files d'attentes de plusieurs
kilomètres de long il espère pouvoir
embarquer dans ses soixante dix autocars
de la croix rouge
l'ampleur de cette catastrophe
humanitaire est tout simplement
incompréhensible des civils par
centaines et essaie de monter dans les
autocars et nous la croix rouge essayons
d'escorté ce qu'on voit à travers les
lignes et de le ramener en sécurité ce
mardi environ 29 mille personnes ont été
évacuées de plusieurs villages et au
total près de 3 millions d'ukrainiens
ont déjà quitté le pays